hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast immunoassays and pain
management drug testing I'm Robert
Castellanos of lab Rhodes and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
education web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of attaining your credits I
would like to introduce today's speaker
dr. margiana dr. Mariana is a director
at Siemens health of inners he received
his PhD in biochemistry from Queens
University working on the structure
mechanism and drug interaction of otto
kato reductases he led projects and
development and commercialization of
drugs of abuse pain management and in EO
suppressant the aminos assays dr.
Marciano has 24 years of experience in
the diagnostic industry his current work
focus include immunoassays and
application development on the multiple
instruments he is a member of the ASB MB
soft & AACC and has published
peer-reviewed papers in abstracts and
inventor on patents he is on the
editorial board of
technology and applied biochemistry and
served as an editorial board of the
internet of journal genomics and
proteomics I'll now turn it over to the
doctor for his presentation pain
management drug testing to go through
and the the goal of my presentation is
to enhance knowledge of Amina as they
use in detection of drugs and to better
understand amino acids features and
testing results
what is amino acid amino as they refer
into the technique that you are utilized
antibody to react with the specific
drugs or antigen in order to measure
their concentrations the antibodies
could be directed toward a specific drug
or class of a drug in order to measure
the drugs
a drug label marker used for 2 months or
the reaction the marker can be an enzyme
fluorophore particles depending on the
technology most of the drug detection
tests are homogeneous immunes i'm
immunoassay enzymes are the ideal
molecule for enzyme immunoassays because
they can amplify the signal of the
reaction activity of the enzyme label
drug can be modulated or changed when
binding to the antibody automated drug
test which I'm going to concentrate on
right in this presentation most of this
automated our immunoassays there are
different technology used for drug
testing including image technologies
cedia spi a and
Kym's immunoassay technique used both
monotone monotonal and polyclonal
antibodies and those as they mainly used
for initial screening of drugs but
especially in urine drug testing and
also my country I'm concentrating on
this in this presentation automated drug
testing also it could be used put in the
treatment plan for patients on
prescription drug drugs other technique
amino acid technique used such as Eliza
and point-of-care all amino acid based
technique enzyme homogeneous amino acids
are competitive acids very successful to
to monitor to use with a small molecule
it can detect up to nano molar levels of
drugs and could be applied on multiple
system or multiple analyzers there are
they are based on a three on three
principles one is the ability of mod or
modulation of the enzyme by analyte and
modulation of the enzyme activity or
enzyme conjugate activity by binding to
the antibody and also enzyme catalysis
reactions so enzyme act as signal
amplifier for antibody antigen
interaction and lastly is the
interaction between drug and antibody is
important to initiate the assay or the
reaction
now if we have a drug present in the
sample what would happen the most of the
antibody in any reaction was bind to a
drug the drug or free drug in the sample
let's antibody will bind to the enzyme
drug conjugate leaving us with a large
large concentration of enzyme conjugate
or drug enzyme labelled enzyme that
causing would lead to higher activity
and reflected in the high concentration
of the truck if we have low
concentration or no concentration of
drugs present in the sample less drug
would bind to the antibody more enzyme
label drugs will bind to an antibody
causing inhibition or lowering activity
of the conjugate or the enzyme conjugate
and therefore reflecting the lower
concentration of the drug how the
reaction proceed
sample the drug drug in the sample added
quote the sample added to the incubated
with the antibody including the enzyme
substrates then with short incubation
the enzyme conjugate or enzyme label
drug will be added competing with the
free drugs to the antibody binding sites
the bound antibodies will get inhibited
but about in bound antibody causing
inhibition of this enzyme conjugate and
the free conjugate in the reaction
mixture stays active causing conversion
of the substrate in this case glucose
6-phosphate dehydrogenase enzyme and the
substrate is glucose 6-phosphate
coenzyme nad producing a product and
NADH which can be monitored at 340
nanometer what concentrate consideration
we need to be a consideration for
selection of antibody to test for drug
or to develop assays for drugs
first if you select import on an
antibody molecule and antibody we have
to maintain a lot lot consistency as and
minimize the variability between
different leads of different pools
secondly maintain supply of the antibody
basically giving the animal alive in
order to take lead from them thirdly is
consistent supplies immunogen so we can
immunize more animals monoclonal
antibodies very consistent between lots
and consistency in in also in
specificity can be produced in many
different animals the third part in
consideration is detection what do we
want to detect do we want to take entire
class of drugs such as Benz there has
been a single drugs
and metabolites or parent drug
metabolites and related drugs such as
ecstasy and opiates or drugs enantiomers
such as FL amine the D and L and fed
amine group or sink very specific drugs
such as 6's steel morphine that required
specific antibody or metallic testing
metabolite or detection of metabolites
such as the cocaine metabolites in this
case antibodies specificity and cross
reactivity what antibody specificity is
it's really the ability of the
individual antibody to are to react with
specific drugs or the ability of
population of antibody to react with
only one drug so more specific to
certain drug and it has the ability to
distinguish between a targeted drugs and
related structurally related drugs in
this case you see on the top here the
kind of specificity cross reactivity the
opposite where the antibody ability of
the antibodies to react with multiple
drugs more than one antigenic
determinant more and more than one drug
or ability of population of antibody to
react with more than one drug and this
interaction could be through through
sharing the epitope excite of the target
analyte or have the epitope a size for
the cross reactant is similar to that of
the targeted drug immunoassay cross
reactivity testing when you test for
immunoassay is for drugs that give you
two type of result no cross reactivity
testing can give you a key to testing
two different two different ways one is
identifying the draw
the constitution of drugs that give you
an equivalent response to their cutoff
secondly is calculating our determining
the percent cross-reactivity of a drug
determined percent percent cost of a
drug is really misleading more
appropriate for customer or people who
tested by using immunoassay to
understand the what concentration of a
cross-react and that give you positive
result or give you a result that is
equivalent to the cutoff what kind of
cross accent we encounter when we
develop assays one is desirable
those are desirable draw structurally
related drug and metabolites
so there are structurally related to the
targeted drug and you want to detect
them preferably to detecting such as
oxymorphone detection with obstacle and
assay insufficient detection of these
drugs will lead to false positive or
false negative results the second group
of cross has an R and desirable
structurally related drug that is drugs
that structurally related to the target
analyte but we don't want them to be
detected by the assay in this case with
amphetamine as a detection of ephedrine
or pseudoephedrine which are structural
laser and feta mean can cause false
positive results the third group is
undesirable structurally and related
drugs in the an example for that the
cross reactivity of a try to down which
is shot with an ecstasy athlete this
kind of cross reactivity is very
challenging and problematic in any amino
sa testing so what can is drugs antibody
we can use in immunoassay
one example I put here on the left is
using two monoclonal antibody - to have
a set amino acid that picks up and fed
amine and methamphetamine and then as
you see here the standard curves are
very super imposable the second party
could use a polyclonal antibody to
detect a drug a related drugs and
metabolites in this case an example is
ecstasy in polyfill antibody will pick
up MDMA MD EA and MD a the third on the
right it's a specific acid which is used
monoclonal antibody to detect a single
drug in this case 6 s still morphine
immunoassay testing protocol
immunoassays give you two type of
results that the one qualitative testing
which provide you with the sample
testing as positive or negative versus a
predetermined cutoff or threshold
testing this testing is very useful in
detecting for initial drug testing for
initial drug screening for detecting the
presence of absence of drug versus the
cutoff level reporting positive and
negative results of a sample does not
reflect the concentration of this sample
versus a cut-off the second part of
testing was called semi quantitative
because it provides approximate
concentration of a drug metabolites or a
class of drugs and this is concentrated
sermon even in nano grams of a mill or
micrograms per mil testing this kind of
testing is very useful in drug
monitoring
assisting patient samples also useful
for determining if you wanted to further
investigate sample and you want to know
the concentration of this sample for
conformation purpose or other purposes
semi-quantitative testing would be very
useful immunity cut-offs
Venus's for drugs I see on the left here
on the right here a list of amino acids
available in the market the first seven
are the work replaced as testing testing
for workplace testing drugs and those
are they have offered urine drug testing
for those as they offer at least one cut
off some of them to some of the three
cut-offs the one involved or the cutoff
the mandated cut-offs
or Sam Simon is cutoff for workplace
drug testing and 30-meter example has
three cut-offs available in the market
300 500 1000 the 500 is a mandated
cutoff oxycodone hydrocodone
there are proposed guidelines for
testing those drugs at the level of 100
and 300 respectively but has had not
been implemented yet rest of it other
drugs also available in two or three two
one or two cutoff people nor Fame 5 and
10 nanograms and mill example tramadol
200 nanograms and mill probe ecstasy 15
390 grams middle all these assay used in
urine drug testing but also there are
proposed guidelines by Samsa for other
other matrices such as oral oral fluids
in drug testing it is important to
understand the separation between the
cutoff and controls or a cutoff and
positive sample and negative sample
federally-mandated tests required to
test controllers at plus minus 25% of
the cutoff and can be used for pain
management testing now if you're running
cutoff uncontrolled on multiple
replicates the it's ideally that overlap
between the lowest and the highest
result of any negative or positive
control advocate of overlap would be a
zero however if the high results of a
negative sample or negative control
overlap with the cutoff causing as you
see here the negative sample to give you
false positive results or if the lowest
consistent lower lowest number or data
from the control over love with the
cutoff causing false negative results of
the sample and as you see here are not
any on the left and overlap statistical
level between the cutoff and control for
six a MSA the overlap is zero that means
none of those in equal 20 tested for
each level overlap with the cutoff
if you know has a detection capabilities
expressed in two and two ways isn't
really the smallest concentration that
can be detected or quantitated through
the calculation of limit of detection
and limit of quantitation limited
detection is useful the discriminative
presence or absence of a drug in the
sample limits quantity of quantitation
lrq very viewers confuse reliably or
useful for reliable measurement of drugs
in samples now how important is the
limit detection for drug screening the
fact that most of a limit of
quantitation or session are much lower
than the cutoff level so there are
limited usage or benefit of using
limiters detection in initial screening
however if you if you want to detect the
drugs of interest in the clinical sample
of you will already want to test the
absence of drug and eClinical sample the
limit of quantitation is may be useful
opioids
or the most prescribed drugs for pain
management opiates and opiates or the
the term is used interchangeably between
the two however the opiates are the one
that are natural alkaloids derived from
Bobby populism present such as morphine
codeine the semi synthetic opioids and
synthetic opioids are the semi synthetic
opiates are driven from the natural
abuse however fully synthetic opiates
such as methadone propoxyphene fentanyl
also used for pain management
opiate asses opiate asses usually used
for detection of morphine and codeine
but also and many essays in the market
use either personal antibody or
monoclonal antibody
however obvious acid opiate assays picks
up or detect hydrocodone hydromorphone
about opioids and also detect
6's still morphine and that hydrocodone
and some to some extent deep in orphan
however none of the opiate assays detect
well obstacle on oxymorphone therefore
those two drugs required a separate
assay for their detection the cutoff
offered for opiate there are the low
cutoff of the 300 milligrams milk the
mandated cutoff 2009 runs below 300 karo
cutoff is more sensitive for pain
management and drug testing monitoring
and the structure and this structure
unrelated cross drug cross reactivity
with some of those obvious assays I
quite common and this is an example here
for structurally and related drug
interferes with opiate se
so opiate as here here in this table a
comparison between the cross reactivity
of for obvious assays as a 300
milligrams and will cut off as you see
all the assays picks up or detect
codeine and morphine very well
however detection of oxycodone and
oxymorphone oxycodone and oxymorphone
are not very well
you know reliable and and required high
concentration of those drugs to be
present in order for the ad c2 victim
hop
however hydrocodone and hydromorphone
detectives added concentration with some
asses which is very close to the 300
cutoff the same for successful morphine
and morphine city glucan naloxone is not
detected which is very good positive it
was a number of those essays at a very
high concentration now a positive sample
of four from an opiate assay doesn't
prove that the sample would have
morphine and codeine present in it we
found out one of the sample we tested
recently was which was positive at 2009
a grams of milk does not have codeine
and morphine rather it has high
concentration of oxycodone oxycodone
about 50,000 not 57,000 nano grams of
milk in order to understand Oviatt is
the result of interpreter results you
understand the opiate metabolism and
opiate as in using those assets have
different cross reactivity profile and
as you see here hope it metabolism and
see morphine coming mainly from poppy
seed ingestion but also morphine is a
metabolite because morphine coming from
successful morphine which a metabolite
of heroin codeine get metabolized to
morphine codeine to hydrocodone morphine
to hydromorphone
so in order to understand the the result
you understand the relative
concentration of those drugs in
Sanchi and pain management and this is
concerning oxycodone and oxy more phone
recently last year actually a Samsa
proposed or published and proposed
guidelines for guar testing for
obstacles and oxymorphone and
hydrocodone hydromorphone as as part of
the initial Federal Work workplace
screening of testing the cutoff proposed
are 100 nanograms mill bill Mills for
oxycodone 300 nanograms per ml for
hydrocodone allow me to confirm those
drugs at lower level as you see here for
oxycodone 50 obstacles or 50 hydrocodone
for hydro mo hydromorphone 54
hydromorphone hydrocodone 50 100
hydrocodone and 100 hydro more phone and
also oxycodone as they should recover
should have cross reactivity with
oxymorphone at the level of 80% or above
the same for hydrocodone as they must
have must cross react with hydro more
phone at level of 80% or above oxycodone
as this data was published by Kunz and
his group on metabolism of or excretion
of hydrocodone oxycodone oxycontin in
urine sample after those of 20 nanograms
20 milligrams oxycodone in 12 subjects
and as you see here in this diagram
actually the oxy oxy
not seek more phone and oxycodone
appears the highest it was in tests
first 10 hours followed by
oxymorphone an oxy more for
after 10 hours they they stay be above
the cutoff level which is 1,500 1,500
rounds ml for the duration of at least
30 30 hours
Soni metabolism of oxycodone oxycodone
can meet up meet applause - the
oxycodone - oxymorphone an oxy more
phone oxymorphone is an active meet up
an active metabolite however not oxy
more phone and oxycodone : or relatively
inactive oxycodone acids in the market
offered as I mentioned was 300 and 100
cutoff cross-reactivity - oxy more for
of a similar phone should be equal
greater than 80% and most of the ad says
they meet that oxycodone acids have
minimum cross reactivity to codeine and
morphine as published in the package
insert of those assays the 100 off and
may be suitable for screening and
monitoring monitoring oxycodone and
oxymorphone and as you see here a table
show the cross reactivity of a number of
opioids at 100 oxycodone 100 nanograms
per mil level what do you see that the
all the acids have good cross reactivity
or higher number four for up codeine and
morphine which is good and the same for
six S steel morphine hydrocodone
hydromorphone
some of the ads they have do cross-react
with naloxone at no Mack exam devil
hydrocodone is also a semi-synthetic
opioid its metabolism was studied by
cohn and others and publishes g80
Journal of the toxicology and the study
was done after following a single 20
milligram dose over four four thirty out
for greater than 30 hours using 12
subjects and as you see he is within the
first ten hours the hydrocodone and
hydromorphone are the highest metabolite
followed by the hydromorphone and they
had a code so the level of those drugs
orbit albumin and metabolites stays
above the cutoff level used which is 100
nanograms of milk for over 13 30 hours
so hydrocodone is metabolized into known
hydrocodone and hydromorphone and
dihydrocodeine now hydromorphone is an
active metabolite however known
hydrocodone is less active metabolites
for hydrocodone
hydrocodone ad sales offered with 100
and 300 cutoff cross-reactivity at a 100
cutoff level is greater than 80 percent
for hydromorphone
however crush a TSP of those as a
available to oxycodone oxymorphone and
for codeine and morphine is not that
that great so for example codeine
cross-react was one of the SE at 3000
code and morphine at five thousand nine
across the mill at the 100 cutoff so the
possibility the fact that they have some
cross-reactive is do codeine morphine
oxycodone and more oxymorphone
is a possibility that we get false
positive result or false negative result
depend on on on me metabolism
buprenorphine assay available in the
market as well which took off five
hundred five nanograms of milk and 10
nanograms been milk as described in the
package inserts of all those essays they
have Botox activity to naloxone and also
to codeine morphine however some of the
assays somewhat report literature
reported some across cross reactivity of
given orphan sa epinephrine assay with
codeine which code with morphine and
other opioids
none of the assays are detect
we know between norepinephrine and
they're metabolize the kurenai's the
assay available picks up one metabolized
one parent compound and metabolites
example image as a big up could peeping
orphan and or with an orphan covalently
CDSA picks up also picks up
given orphan and nor we've been offering
local denied the other two assays picks
up the same people no people faint i'm
not even talking fentanyl is one of the
high potency i a drugs most of the
cut-off available mug as a to nanograms
per mil cutoff they have minimum cross
reactivity at least for one as a minimum
cross reactivity to codeine morphine and
hydrocodone and low both assays
available here have low cross reactivity
toward north fentanyl so the possibility
is a lot of cross reactivity to a major
metabolite causing may cause false false
negative results with its assets vince
desi being also prescribed although
described for an exact entirety insomnia
and seizure so on but also given as as
for for pain metabolism of those
compounds are very complex complicated
at least five essays as is available
from the market using part on antibodies
all the as they use different
calibrators or different pills there's a
being compiled in the collaborators they
tried to ban excessive am
diazepam cutoff availables or 200 and
300 cutoff and both of them could be
used for pain management testing the
fault with these these since there's
been a failure always false positive
results could come from the last first
the lack of cross reactivity was or
other all the pins there has been
secondly is with the structuring and
related drugs might cause false positive
result as well
the primary challenge which means there
has been acid is the lack of cross
reactivity or detection of metabolites
such as visitors being Clicquot night
this day as being blue tonight the seven
amino and alpha hydroxy metabolites and
as you see here those are metabolism
metabolites from parent compounds some
of manufacturer included a blue colonies
pretreatment
step either on board or manual to stasis
look blue colonize
by using lower cut off including click
on these three steps you will increase
the sensitivity of this assay and
specificity of those assay for for
testing and feta means available in
three cutoff levels in the assay able to
use monitor or Parlophone antibodies and
they have equal detection of dnfed amine
and the methamphetamine at the cutoff
level some art is also because up access
to drugs MDMA and DEA and
MDA the tarifa cutoff 300 cutoff is a
more sensitive cutoff if your acting is
very specific specific and so you will
be able to use this low cutoff for pain
management testing and you have to take
in consideration basically the
cross-reactivity profile of the of the
of the a say such area related drugs is
a major problem this assay is such as
ephedrine and pseudoephedrine and so on
and also cross the activity was
structurally and related drugs such as
traged or transit rated on the bits of
all Thomason is imposing a problem and
causing false positive result why cross
reactivity of amphetamines is a key
because in the key challenge for this
ads is because the structural similarity
between the structurally desirable drug
and undesirable truck the drugs you want
to detect and they want the one you
don't want to detect but they are
structurally related drugs to your
target truck and philomene share
amphetamine share common structure that
includes phenyl ring herbicides chain
and amino amino group and as you see
here in the picture that this the
structure of amphetamine methamphetamine
ephedrine to the ephedrine and so on or
are quite similar and have the same
structural elements so those drugs are
likely to cross-react with amphetamine
instead I mean as they if your if your
antibody is not very specific
other trucks available in the market for
pain pain testing May 13 at 200
nanograms windmill cutoff is only one
acid currently in the market has
alternatives to two other opioids and
the drug is metabolized to normal
mobility and it's important that you the
asset would have cross reactivity to
this metabolite in order to avoid false
negative results
tramadol it's prescribed widely and
metabolized into a major metabolite the
end and or dismissal tramadol cutoff was
available it's 200 nanograms of emil and
widely used in detection of tramadol and
its metabolites methadone the to cutoff
availables or 150 and 300 most of the
methadone assays have pork roast at
least to the ebdb and the major
metabolite causing false positive false
negative results so it's important to
combine testing of methadone with
testing of EDD be specific si
a drug during drug testing screen screen
result the result could be a result of
drug testing could be true positive
sample could be true negative result
that's mean
the drug is absent or an example or
ingested not ingested by the patient or
drug the greatest in the sample or not
collected within the collection window
if you the true positive samples which
indicate with a drug its president
sample and require confirmation also the
drop the assay is very specific and
picking up only the drug but not other
compounds false positive results getting
its mean our prescription and
non-prescription drugs are present and
picked up and this is required basically
that apply for many of the class add
such as such as amphetamine is there has
been obvious and required confirmation
false negative results or when a drug is
emits or metabolite is present but not
detected by the assay and require then
alternative method for detection for
confirmation confirmation testing have
only one slide on it LCMS and DCMS being
used and those techniques are just
artistic techniques identify individual
drugs in part in positive sample an
example of interest confirmation
cut-offs usually there are four drugs
for workplace drug testing there are
there are confirmation cutoff levels
which are lower than the cutoff levels
proposed by by Samsa except except we
have six still morphine and VCB the
cutoff and calm
my concentration or the same
confirmation of a class of si is the
challenging for and it's me need to be
understood in the scope of the test
confirmation is not done and it's done
on drug of interest as well when you
have some kind of negative result to
make in order to detect patient if
patient taking a drugs or in clinical
interpretation of any results in
compliance immunity and compliance
monitoring you know as they are useful
in patient overall compliance useful in
determining the source of a group a
group of drugs or at nutri provide
information on non compliance and
adherence as well cut-off low cutoff of
those number of assays may be useful
useful tool for monitoring compliance
for drug so finally in our conclusion in
this presentation
I would like to say we covered the
immunity as are available are available
to test the in management drugs
especially on the Bo cutoff level assays
specificity varies from amino acids
between amino acids use understanding
immunity characteristic their cross
reactivity and features are important in
in interpretation of the results thank
you
well thank you very much for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience has been the questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button a thermally left
at the presentation window we're going
to try to answer as many questions as
time allows doctorate our first question
is what is the ideal analytical method
for drawing and the idea of method has
been used widely use GCMs but recently
lc/ms becoming more in the LCMS is
becoming the method of choice because
its sensitivity and the ability of
detect to sense to lower levels detects
drugs in the samples thank you do you
think LC ms/ms si will eventually
replace ia when the blades there can you
repeat your question please I'm not a
problem do you think LC ms/ms si will
eventually replace ia I don't I don't
think so the reason for that is amino
acids are especially automated immune as
they used to screen thousand or samples
it's a very fast efficient way of
screening sample although their
potential of sometime positive or
negative results that you need to be
confirmed
however if you want to test everything
using using lcms they have to be very
costly and time-consuming
thank you and with the time that we have
it looks like we have time for one last
question here and it's what are the
drawbacks of immunoassays of drug method
amino acid it's the lead is the amino
acid is depend on it I'm actually the
specific it's specificity and the amino
acids if amino acids are specific so be
able to pick up the drugs you want the
drawback is well the cross reactivity of
amino acids not all universities have
the same cross reactivity profile
some of them would react with
structurally related compound others
with the structurally unrelated and
causing false positives that required
confirmation and then cost cause the lab
more and more you know and fun so cross
reactivity is the immunoassay is
especially automated immunity are
expensive for labs to you have to really
acquire an instrument which those
instruments are expensive but and and if
you if you are largely medium-sized that
even small sub lab which is you can use
those automated assays and there are
different sizes of instrument you can
use that that suit your you know
capability right thinking I actually
have one last question here that we
might have time for are two different
technology a must for reporting a
conformity result when you view this
question again see
none of them are too different
technology a must for reporting a
conformity result well as I mentioned in
the different technologies different
technology also has have some their own
influence on it's all but the most
important things are really what you
using with the antibody using in your ad
says that the antibodies are specific
your law you you'll be getting results
reflect is selected in and the actual
concentration of the trucks and a sample
minimum amount of positive and negative
negative fault - negative
false positive so the the difference is
the main difference between between
assays although there are differences
the technology influences the
performance of assays its ability to to
the efficiency of the acid test
but the antibodies are very important in
determining those whether this acid are
or they give you you know the result
that reflects what's in the sample thank
you and do you have any final comments
today doctor before we let you go
hello
oh yeah and do you have any final
comments today doctor you know just I'm
just once a for for drug testing pain
management drug testing this I would say
the although there's no cut-off assays
would be very suitable for for drug
testing although we have one has to look
at the cross relativity profile of the
assay if they ask a very more specific
you could use those low cutoff for pain
management testing and it would be
convenient and also useful and at the
end of like very much thank you and that
route for for giving me opportunity to
present well thank you doctor and I also
like to thank Rohan routes as well for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
February of 2017 you'll receive an email
from lab routes alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay
we'll invite you to for that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye